now what I begin I think it's a bit
weird because I could deal with this as
a standard form if it was the reciprocal
of that integrate right if it was one
over the square root of both wha what am
I going to what am I expecting basically
yeah slightly that's right so I'm just
going to muck around with the
coefficients and I'll be fine that'll be
okay but this as it stands is not a
standard form however it is close to
something that iran denies right if I
just think about Oh what is this
function what does it actually represent
because what i want rayvin it's a
definite integral what I want is an area
right 10 what is an area so if I think
about this if I square both sides and
note the fact that the original equation
has a restriction that disappears once
I've square that so I'm just going to
state it okay what is this thing what is
this in this is an ellipse right it's
super easy to see once you haven't like
this okay so it's been a it's been
squashed together okay it's like a
circle and you've crabbed it in four
times I don't have a formula for the
area of an ellipse I could think about
the area of a circle and then do some
scaling business okay there's no reason
to you know sort of go to that recourse
if I just think back to making an
appropriate substitution what would
change how would I change this in order
to make that actually as circle what I
do what would have change over here to
end up with a circle maybe I should I
says why is this of ellipses not a
circle it's because of this coefficient
right man is because these coefficients
are not the same right so if for
instance this was an x squared rather
than a 4x squared this guy this guy then
i would have a circle circles are super
easy to deal with right I'm just gonna
use into an area formula so therefore
what I really want him to be is rather
than you know a multiple of some square
I just want it to be a square so i'm
going to write it like this i'm going to
say because i'm not to do a substitution
x equals 0
and x equals five on two and i'm going
to rewrite this as 4x squared is
something squared or square right what
is it 2x right so i'm going to write it
to make that clear up and they'll raise
you my substitution right because this
is a simple one I'm just going to do
this I think we can do this in our heads
and do it quickly I'm going to let u
equal to X right so what's do you or DX
it's too I don't have it to be this i'ma
have to compensate by multiplying by a
half so this is what I'm going to get if
you're equals to x and x equals 0 what
will u equal to x 0 is still 0 when x
equals 5 on to you is double that so I'm
going up to a five yep I chose the
substitution to x equals V you so that's
what I've got there right this DX is
still there but the way I resolve it is
that D or D X is 2 so 1 which is in
there is half D or D actually we've
written this before right so I'm going
to have half do you on DX there cancel
cancel I'm ready to integrate okay or
rather than integrate evaluate this
integral because what is this guy right
this is just a semicircle but I'm only
interested in like this is negative 5 25
I'm really interested in this part right
you see that so I'm getting our quadrant
which is a quarter of a circle all right
the area of a circle is pi times the
radius squared right which in this case
is 5 squared but don't forget is
actually a half here which I could have
put at the front here and something i
just multiply through by that does that
make sense I it's definite so that's why
there's no closer iteration so it looks
like I've got 25 pie on it okay
so very very simple I can't like i said
before i could approach it as a circle
then do like some scaling business
there's no reason to when we can choose
a perfectly good substitution and turn
something elliptical eat to a sec what
use do with a first-rate